امامي اكبر طائره شحن في العالم وهي
انطونوف 225 التي يبلغ طولها اكثر من 84
مترا وتستطيع حمل 250 طن من عمليات الشحن
هذه الطائره التي دمرت من قبل القوات
الروسيه عندما دخلت مدينه جوستمر الواقعه
شمال العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
مسترديناري رودينك لو يحدثنا او تحدثنا عن
كيف قامت القوات الروسيه بتدمير هذه
الطائره
لكن القوات الاوكرانيه منعتهما وقبل
انسحابهم دمروا العديد من الطائرات كما
اجبروا احدى طائرات الشحن على الهبوط
الطائره المزوده ب6 محركات وزن كل محرك
يصل الى اكثر من 5, 600 كيلو جرام وكذلك
مزوده ب 40 عجله السيد فلودو ميرسي وهو
مهندس تكنيكي لهذه الطائره تحدثنا عن
التكنيك لهذه الطائره وكيف اصبحت حطها في
شخص من خوري مجهزه تقنيه لكن لا نستطيع
اصلاحها وتحتاج عملا كبيرا ووقتا طويلا
تحاول اعاده بناء وصيانه هذه الطائره
الجديده رغم انها مدمر بشكل كامل مع
حديثها على قدرتها بناء طائره حديثه
وجديده اذا دعمتها الحكومه الاوكرانيه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث هانس فيان جوستوميل
شمال كيه